we got some new merch made but it's only
exclusive for our petrie honors
so if you go on our patreon we got some
new tiers we got the coffee mug tear
and the hoodie tier and if you're
defibrillator you get
both so make sure you go to patreon
check that out and thank you guys so
much for supporting and enjoy the video
[Music]
this got my attention it's actually a uh
it was a dr phil episode and it was
about a 56 year old woman who
currently is considering divorcing her
10th husband
tenth damn why does she choose so many
bad guys she's got commitment issues
so picky yes so at 56 years old she's
also saying that she doesn't
plan to stop getting married until she
finds mr
wright and so let's all play uh dr phil
now
and uh i gotta look like a walrus first
what kind of person do you gotta be to
go into ten marriages and not know how
to
properly a i think select a a better
partner
and also learn to commit and work things
out
well i mean first of all kudos to her
she got 10 marriage proposals mm-hmm
yeah that's amazing
like what was the guy thinking after
number nine you know you're like this
one
no lucky tim do you think that she
doesn't tell them
about her previous marriages i mean
she's got an article in the
whatever now yeah number 11 is gonna
know for maybe she's the one proposing
oh no
yeah maybe maybe i'm just curious what
kind of guy she's dating
well she has like that does she say what
kind of yes she is she like
annie yesterday who's like i only date
jersey guys like if she keeps picking
one type of guy
maybe that's no it's all it's all
different so she's mentioned that she's
married all types of men from
a rocker to a preacher to her high
school sweetheart so it's like the full
spec sounds like a baller to me
a oh here's the here's a picture of her
bam maybe she should stop getting
married maybe that's maybe she should
date a little
yeah like just jumping in too she's very
passionate
this is oh wow her name is cassie she
looks like dr phil
she does kind of like with the wig on
yeah it looks like a cocker spaniel a
little bit
i wish we could see a younger photo of
her yeah a little bit yeah she must have
been
pretty she looks great for food right
for sure
really no no well i mean like i thought
her necklace looked good for 56.
i'm from kansas girl you see everything
there all right
i got it because uh walmart peoples oh
walmart people
her hair's nice she's got nothing
against kansas she looks like she has
morning breath after she brushes her
teeth
huh i know someone like that really
does not maybe it's the doctor phil
lighting though
oh dr phil lightings i'm sure she has an
enigmatic personality
oh yes that's true she looks like she's
a [ __ ]
a party to be around dude it's dead her
smile
they caught her at the worst moment when
she's like a
bulldog are there any other photos of
her i know why are we talking [ __ ] about
this lady
well because she looks like a captain
planet villain they don't even give her
full name
actually like miss trash but at least
they had a female villain that's kind of
cool for once yeah
she has that he-man haircut that's so
[ __ ] up
lady litter that's her name lady litters
she's probably a sweet sweet woman she's
so so nice though yeah only 10 divorces
must be
i mean maybe she i don't know
like she she comes from a place where
you have to be
the culturally like married or whatever
like it this it's it's still
even ten times though i don't know ten
times is a lot because
why can't she just date is my question
is so weird what if that's her branding
like she just doesn't like to finish
anything like she'll drink a glass of
water and then she's a little bit left
she's like
i can't i have to walk away she gets a
potato chip and she bites half and
throws the other one she throws it away
i've had 10 foreclosures like 10 car
leases at the same time
geo she leaves this much left in the
glass and she gets a new glass exactly
does that drive women nuts or what
i see that it is interesting though it's
interesting having two married couples
in the room because
i feel like in my 20s i started seeing
like a big difference with how people
were
engaging with dating because of apps and
all you know just the endless options
and i was like is it
is it really impossible for our
generation to really settle down and i
don't think we know the answer yet
because we haven't been in it long
enough to see
true it doesn't feel like there's
commitment issues now with the younger
generation maybe she wants to be part of
the younger generation she's like well i
never got to do
internet dating i never got to be on
tinder maybe that was just her instinct
yeah but you're right though i do feel
like there's a lot of like
seems like options are at her fingertips
literally and
and with that many options it's really
hard to kind of settle
didn't we already go through this like
during the romantic
era into classic
that's too historical right now we talk
about what you know what's a romantic
yeah
with the romantic area well because
though well in art uh february that time
everywhere everything was about
romanticism and like getting married and
like
love and all that stuff and then after
that i think it was um
i don't know how to pronounce his name
go go goatee go go terror or whatever or
that guy is here
yeah or like uh i might get
mixed up but i think he was the one that
was talking about how like
the the the the realism of like marriage
or like
love or whatever it ends up running out
anyway
that's how it looks like but that's
that's that's how you say that go tear
or something i'm so sad that you picked
that up i know
it's not goatee don't look up goatsy
don't
don't
e-t-h-e if you google it it's a guy
holding his [ __ ]
all the way open yeah it's a guy bent
over and he's holding his [ __ ]
how do you guys know that where the [ __ ]
do you go what it reminds me
is like on the internet itself
right now where there was an era where
everyone just romanticized
uh that type of love and it's happily
ever after
and then in reality like that's not the
case right so they
it is for us joe uh same [ __ ] hold my
hand
don't shake my head and i rest my case
as they shake hands like this
we're married we do the warrior shakes
make sure we don't have [ __ ] weapons
to kill each other we reproduce
that's so cute
karen is like i wish i had that
one day my husband will shake my hand
one of these days
so yeah back to this lady so her longest
marriage
was her first marriage it lasted eight
years and
that's good it's really good i think she
you know they they
went through the trials and tribulations
eight years definitely uh and then it
ended mutually
and uh the article doesn't really go
into detail i didn't watch the whole
episode
uh but then her second marriage is kind
of where it starts to get
more interesting uh it's slightly
shorter at seven years
um whoa it's still a long time she
actually gives it a go
yes but then this is the part where i
think there's a
somewhat of a downward spiral where then
they had a son together
so she has children as well mind you so
this this kid's this sons
had like ten dads like nine step dads
[ __ ] um
oh my god uh but the relationship
started falling apart whenever that
the second husband stopped telling her
that he loved her
and he would simply say ditto now
girl oh my god what do you what do you
take from that
like when a man just goes ditto that's
weird well she probably didn't earn it
that is the han solo move though i mean
unless it's like a cutesy thing
but it sounds like it was not a cutesy
no if it was a cutesy thing it was it
did not register
this isn't that what happens in ghost oh
yeah
doesn't she say i love you and he says
ditto and that's how he she knows that
ghost is back it's like the most
loving part of the movie oh maybe he's
absolutely right
so she broke up with him on wrong terms
i love that movie
this guy was trying to recreate that
love from that movie only she knew right
and then she did and this would have
been around the right time right the 80s
but maybe it's the delivery maybe he's
like ditto
ditto [ __ ] it's the thought of having
to love her
damn so yeah um well that's a great
point um but then after that
uh she kind of just doesn't really go
into details from the husband's number
three to ten
because they're all blur they're all the
boys or they married the next four of
them at the same time
maybe but the the preacher the rocker
and also the high school sweetheart are
among
the this batch of men was this a sims
expansion
the expansion pack you wanted to try
different flavors she wanted to try
different and it doesn't count as a high
school sweetheart if you've been married
high school sweetheart is someone you're
with in high school and it carries all
the way over not
you're you're dating in high school and
then you had a huge break and then you
get back with them
no that's not how it works you mean i
never heard of i thought it was just you
guys were sweethearts in high school yes
yeah yeah that's it you're sweethearts
in high school and you carry it all the
way through
no you dated high school you you broke
up you had a real time
a real life and then you're like oh i'm
sad maybe i could recreate this
existence
i thought that was re recreating this
existence am i wrong
[Laughter]
i mean i think you made up your own rule
that this high school sweetheart
welcome to my marriage
that just means you guys were
sweethearts in high school but what
happens in between
it doesn't matter i will protect you so
that we may breed
we're breed partners
it sounds like this might be the obvious
stuff but it just sounds like this woman
needs to spend time
by herself as a single woman figure her
[ __ ] out
work through her own [ __ ] figure out
what she's been single 10 times
it sounds like she's never single part
she it's just been it's been her and all
these dudes
she just needs to be with her wigs for a
while and just see like which wig
is gonna work for her for real because
like the common
denominator here is that she's in every
relationship so it's not that it's then
it's
her obviously absolutely yeah so the
current and even if it is them she's
choosing them
exactly so it's still her exactly it's
her it's really her her decision
decisions and actions that are leading
her down this path
why do they always have to blame the
woman though
well we don't we haven't heard anything
about the guys so we have to kidding i'm
just kidding
true i'm just saying fair point i'm just
saying this article stands there one way
yeah and so it is kind of it it seems
like okay if all the guys
are are getting with 10 different
marriages too then it just seems like
they're all [ __ ] up people
no this is the woman's thing because she
went on dr phil
so it is it is her yeah she's she's
she's seeking answers from dr phil
and she's looking she's even picking the
wrong doctor
you can't make any good decisions why
would you go to that doctor on a reality
show
reality underrated comment from eugeo by
the way that's right everyone's gonna
know
yeah i loved your comment that was
really good i appreciate that
but i like him because he looks like a
walrus thank you
because he's like you have got to wake
up we just needed a good pair
that's pretty good down the street
that's the doctor
go on yelp lady and find that doctor
what did dr phil say
uh basically that she needs to spend
time by herself oh really
really get to know herself and what she
needs and become
dr geo pretty good isn't it funny how
it's so easy to just diagnose someone
else's [ __ ]
and then go like yeah it's easy right
but when it comes to your own [ __ ]
it's probably simple but we're all blind
to it we're all emotionally involved we
just don't think anymore we're just like
we could sit across the room be like i
know your problem you're a problem okay
this is how you fix it easy
and then you probably have something
really easy to [ __ ] fix but can't do
it
true i wonder what dr phil needs to fix
about himself his hairline maybe
what hairline exactly hey [ __ ] you dude
[Laughter]
[ __ ] you man cut it cut dude cut things
got intense
[Music]
you